pido que empecemos abordando el cargo de
Primer Ministro chino como tal Qué rol y
qué poder tiene realmente
Bueno es un cargo que históricamente ha
tenido poder pero desde Queen ha llegado
en el 2012 al poder en China ha ido
perdiendo su influencia en el caso de
lique change el Primer Ministro saliente
fue una figura importante es un
intelectual brillante realmente con peso
político propio y mucho apoyo de los
empresarios costeros de China no va a
ser la situación de liching que es más
bien un burócrata muy fiel allí que lo
ha acompañado muy de cerca en los
últimos 20 años y que no tiene ni esa
estatura política ni ese brillo tampoco
se espera alguien que más bien va a
ejecutar las decisiones de Sí
precisamente le pido que repasemos ahora
el perfil del lichan no que le
diferencia de su antecesor porque se ha
destacado en el pasado
Bueno es un personaje que ha tenido es
de buen show que es una ciudad costera
que tiene justamente se identifica por
su gran emprendedorismo es una persona
que históricamente también ha estado
vinculada a una visión aperturista en lo
económico pero que desde que desde que
sí ha sido gobernador en la provincia de
chechán una provincia muy importante
allá a principios de los 2000 lichian se
ha convertido en un ladero de él y más
bien una mano derecha en cuanto a las
cuestiones políticas sobre todo ha
estado al frente de Shanghai de la
provincia de changú me refiero a litián
pero no ha sido una de las principales
figuras de la alta burocracia china
nunca ocupó un puesto central en la
administración nacional china por
ejemplo que es algo que todos los
primeros ministros Generalmente tienen
Así que vamos estamos frente a una
figura que probablemente va a tener un
rol muy importante en la gestión Pero
más bien Gris le preguntó precisamente
ahora que abordemos que profundicemos en
lo que usted mencionaba en la relación
entre sí y lee no precisamente porque se
habló mucho en el vigésimo congreso del
partido comunista que shis estaba
rodeando de figuras muy afines a él
por primera vez desde los tiempos de Mao
tenemos un líder que ha centralizado
completamente El Poder y que está
rodeado completamente por figuras
ultrafieles en los máximos cargos como
usted sabe la democracia China tiene sus
características muy particulares que es
más bien interna y órganos y figuras
suelen oficiar como contrapesos la
actual conformación del comité central
los siete miembros más encumbrados el
político buró y por supuesto con el
Primer Ministro como la segunda figura
más importante son todas figuras
ultrafieles así ninguna que pareciera
serle sombra y ninguna de ellas que
tampoco asomaría como un posible sucesor
esto es una gran novedad con respecto a
lo que se viene un tercer mandato
inédito Pero quién sabe también no
estamos frente a un posible cuarto
mandato no
y le pregunto por último a grandes
rasgos Cuáles serían los retos que tiene
el y por delante como Primer Ministro de
China bueno en las dos sesiones que son
las asambleas legislativa que se está
desarrollando todavía el tema es fue la
economía doméstica Por supuesto que la
política exterior pero no nos vamos a
meter en eso porque no va a abocar tanto
la la digamos el rol del Primer Ministro
Yo creo que es implementar reformas
económicas que permitan una recuperación
sólida china es tanto una gran
desaceleración hay una crisis del sector
inmobiliario el impacto de la pandemia
de la guerra en Ucrania se han perdido
muchos empleos yo creo que la prioridad
número uno del Primer Ministro va a ser
eso estabilizar la economía y marcar una
senda de desarrollo que hoy suena
incierta para china en este contexto tan
complicado